[Applause]
[Music]
once upon a time next to a ramshackle
military airport full of old soviet
helicopters and fighters it was a small
town called san antonio de los banos a
city of colonial origin known as the
capital of humor well at least this is
the place where the international
biennial of graphic humor is held
however since july 2021 it could well
start to be better known as the cuban
epicenter of bad mood and social
discontent there are no lack of reasons
cuba is facing its worst shortage of
food since the
1990s cuba recognizes serious shortage
of medicines there in san antonio de la
spanos is where it all began it is the
place where people became fed up and it
is the first place where people lost
their fear and the first mass protests
against the cuban regime appeared at
least the first since 1994
[Music]
these protests as you can see originated
outside havana and quickly spread
throughout the country and particularly
in the provinces of mayabeke and
matanzas where for example the tourist
hub of valdero is located there are
numerous protest rallies in the capital
in havana itself on this occasion the
protests have been somewhat strange not
only because seeing protests in a
communist dictatorship like cuba's is a
rare occurrence but also because it's
the first time that large-scale wave of
protests at least in cuban terms has
started outside the capital
[Music]
unlike what happens in other latin
american countries the communist regime
that has ruled cuba for more than 60
long years has managed to establish a
strong institutional framework that
reaches every corner of the country this
gives the dictatorship a position of
broad dominion and control over the
population as a whole in fact the cuban
regime is one of the few communist
regimes that despite all the
difficulties managed to survive the fall
of the berlin wall and the collapse of
the soviet union what's more the regime
even survived the great economic crisis
that hit the country between 1990 and
1994 a crisis that caused an upsurge in
rationing and severe material shortages
that continue to this day it was a
period in which cuba lost in just three
years 36 of its gdp a blow from which
the country would take more than 17
years to recover
and you see the soviet union was much
more than a political ally for cuba it
was the real economic driver of the
island for decades
[Music]
for example the ussr sold oil to cuba at
preferential prices oil that the cubans
then re-exported in part to obtain
dollars cuba received soft loans from
moscow that is very long-term loans with
very low interest rates and easy
repayment cubans were also compensated
for the presence of the red army troops
on the island and exported the bulk of
their production to the soviet market to
give you an idea approximately 70 of all
cuban trade was directed towards the
union of soviet socialist republics
cuba was more dependent on the ussr than
it had been on spain and the united
states in its entire history juan triana
cuban economist therefore when the ussr
collapsed the cuban economy collapsed
there were very hard years of crisis
during which even the consumption of
calories by cubans was reduced by almost
30 it was a stage known as the special
period years of extreme hardship that
ended up fueling a social explosion the
malacanzo uprising
[Music]
in early august 1994 cuban authorities
detained four boats heading to the
united states to escape the crisis that
was ravaging the island it was the straw
that broke the camel's back hundreds and
hundreds of people gathered on havana's
malaison a broad esplanade armed with
sticks and stones and clashing against
the police wash outing slogans against
the then president dictator fidel castro
nevertheless and in spite of everything
the communist regime remains in power
against all odds an expression that in
cuba we could adapt and say against
crisis and misery how is it possible
that in spite of everything the regime
remains closed to the world to freedom
and to modernity well as i was saying
this is something they have achieved
thanks to the institutionalism they have
spread throughout the country
totalitarian but institutional to the
core
in fact the political institutional
construction of the cuban regime is
largely inherited from the soviet
experience it maintains very refined
power structures at government and
military levels that is to say there are
no traitors or significant internal
struggles in addition the government has
one of the best security and
intelligence services in latin america
that is precisely why despite all the
crises the island has suffered the dream
of achieving freedom and democracy
always seems very different and
difficult to achieve for the cuban
people
[Music]
now at this point i bet most of you are
wondering how on earth did we come to
see the images we have seen of mass
protests in cuba what elements have
unleashed such a social explosion what
is the root cause of these protests and
perhaps the most important question of
all will the protests happen again and
succeed once and for all in toppling the
regime sooner rather than later well you
all know what happened so in this video
we're going to tell you exactly what let
the fuse and how we see the scenario
that have been playing out in cuba check
this out
[Music]
an unstoppable wave of freedom
the cuba of 2021 is not the cuba of the
year 2015 not even the cuba of 2020. the
country has experienced significant
social changes that until a few years
ago would have been quite simply
unthinkable changes that although they
have not been reflected in the
government nor an improvement or the
economy or political freedoms have
changed cuba in some ways for example
despite all the propaganda of the regime
most of the younger cuban generations no
longer see the united states as a
hostile agent but as a kind of model of
what they might one day become and all
the changes that have taken place there
is one thing that has marked a real
turning point the arrival of mobile
internet in fact this has been one of
the factors that has most mobilized
people in the protests of july 2021
we're talking about service that did not
exist on the caribbean island until
relatively recently
2018 mobile internet service would start
on december 6th through the state-owned
telecommunications company e-t-e-c-s-a
the country's only internet provider
cubans can now access the internet
anywhere from the palm of their hands
it's something that has opened doors to
a force that is very difficult to
contain
[Music]
although the internet in cuba is
censored thanks to vpn networks cubans
have managed to open a window to the
outside world and among other things
they can now talk directly and without
filters with their family and friends in
spain or miami clearly this is the best
antidote to political propaganda of
course it's not just about talking the
internet has also given them access to
massive amounts of information brand new
information without prior censorship by
the communist authorities now they can
learn about the outside world discover
different political viewpoints organize
themselves and even participate in
political debates quite a revolution on
the island of cuba
[Music]
now cubans are seeing firsthand the
consequences of being imprisoned on an
island whose government seems frozen in
time while their immigrant compatriots
prosper in the rest of the world and to
top it all off there is the
disappointment the enormous frustration
with the new cuban government
[Music]
you see when raul castro began to hand
over the reins to the island's new
political leader president miguel diaz
chanel there was a great deal of
expectation would this finally be the
leader who would promote openness and
change in cuba in theory diaz canel was
in favor of important reforms opening
cuba to the world allowing private
initiative or direct foreign investment
that is to say to change the course that
so many communist dictatorships have
gone through over the years and yes it
is true that some changes did start
taking place starting with internet
access however other areas have been
very slow too slow desperately slow to
the point that they have barely improved
the economic situation and they've
certainly not lived up to expectations
at the end of the day this is relatively
easy to explain what cubans want in 2021
especially the young is very simple they
want to have the latest model cell
phones that their cousins living in
madrid already have the cars that their
uncles drive in miami people to talk
about whatever they want without fear or
reprisals or simply be able to travel
they want to have a future and a normal
life something the covenant government
doesn't seem willing or prepared to give
them and that is precisely what has been
forging a certain general awareness that
the life they have today simply does not
work it's not quite right they're living
in the name of a revolution that they
never actually supported to make matters
worse the generation that has protested
the most is a generation that was born
during what is known as the special
period the period of severe economic
crisis as we have already seen followed
the collapse of the soviet union in
short this is a generation that has
never experienced anything but crisis
repression rationing and poverty how can
they not be fed up and what's more they
have nothing to lose the way we see it
is that the protests meant one thing the
cubans are losing their fear now what
exactly was the spark that let the fuse
any ideas check this out
[Music]
the final straw
to understand the reasons that led to
the social keg finally exploding in july
2021 we have to bring the coronavirus
into the equation at the time of making
this video cuba had been suffering a
fierce wave of infections for several
months a wave that has literally been
imported from abroad with the approval
of the cuban government itself you see
tourism is a very important source of
income for the regime and therefore it
is vital for its own existence
[Music]
take a look for example at this name
gesa grupo administration imperial i
think it is an organization a consortium
owned by the cuban armed forces it is a
kind of holding company controlling all
kinds of assets retail distribution
stores ports and above all hotels
i have always thought of cuba's economy
in government as an onion or as one of
those russian dolls that contain other
smaller ones inside i have never seen
the last matryoshka i have seen three or
four and i think the same thing happens
with an institution like gaiza pedro
freire attorney for the us cuba business
council of the u.s chamber of commerce
in this lane gesa controls the gavitorek
tourism group a conglomerate that in
turn owns the most important hotels on
the island we are talking about more
than 83 hotel facilities with a total of
29 000 rooms and a turnover in normal
conditions of more than 700 million
dollars well evan 2019 tourist arrivals
to cuba already fell considerably by six
percent in 2020 the results were
catastrophic as a result of the pandemic
the number of international tourists
arriving on the island dropped to
practically zero and the cuban
government lost nearly three billion
dollars in revenue and although in 2021
things have improved a bit compared to
the previous year the cuban tourism
sector is still lagging far behind the
figures of previous years so of course
in such a situation any income counted
[Music]
[Applause]
precisely for that reason the government
decided to look the other way regarding
the pandemic and to encourage the
arrival of international tourists with
almost no restrictions these tourists
came mainly from the country that has
experienced the greatest growth and
tourism to cuba in recent years mother
russia the problem the russians were
suffering from a violent wave of the
coronavirus caused by the delta variant
and the vast majority were still
unvaccinated and that is what explains
news stories like this one
more than 150 russian tourists are in
quarantine in cuba after testing
positive for covid19 and take note that
it was not an isolated case the arrival
of tourists mainly russians began to
cause outbreaks in hotels that later
through the workers ended up spreading
throughout the country although the
province of matanzas was particularly
affected where varadero cuban's
epicenter of sun and beach tourism is
located the spread of infections
collapsed cuba's ailing health system
and caused even more severe shortages of
medicines and basic commodities than
usual now i'm sure you're wondering but
why on earth did they open the doors to
tourism from countries in the midst of
the pandemic due to the new variants
well quite simply because the regime
needed money they urgently needed money
[Music]
it's the 2020 tourism crisis in cuba
that goes a long way to explaining why
cubans now have to wait in long lines to
try to buy food at the supermarket you
see the thing is the food in cuba is
mainly imported because the country
barely produces 20 of the local demand
we are talking about a bill of 1.8
billion dollars in food imports every
year purchases are made on the
international market and have to be paid
in dollars or euros
[Music]
and what is the main source of dollars
and euros for cuba exactly tourism and
since it was hardly any tourism in 2020
that means that getting a hold of the
dollars which the regime needs to import
food becomes very complicated
particularly when you are a country like
cuba that nobody trusts and nobody wants
to lend to because of the us embargo and
that is where the severe shortages that
have punished and continue to punish
cubans come into play it is the fish
that bites its own tale
a tightly constrained and highly
unproductive economy a system of
state-owned companies that is completely
dysfunctional and not subject to market
criteria extreme control of everything
that enters the island in short the
perfect recipe for disaster perhaps the
biggest miscalculation made by the
government is that they never thought
that the situation would get out of
control to the point of unleashing the
largest protests in the history of cuba
protests even larger than those of the
uprising in 1994 to give you an idea 40
demonstrations were registered in a
single day this is obviously not normal
in a country governed with an iron fist
like this one is in fact on the busiest
days of the protests which came to fill
streets and squares in havana cuban
dictator president diaz chanel was quite
nervous in his communities he even urged
civil confrontation between supporters
and opponents of the government
[Music]
revolutionary
that appeal made one thing clear the
cuban regime may not yet be on the verge
of collapse but it is not as solid as it
was thought to be
after cutting off the internet and even
electricity to make assembly more
difficult and deploying security forces
the protests gradually died down police
and military forces have taken over
havana and the country's main cities the
black berets the elite cuban repression
corps and civilian men armed with pvc
pipes and wooden sticks walking groups
through the cities to intimidate the
population
by the way the black berets officially
called the special national brigade our
political police corps whose basic
function is to act as shock squad for
the cuban dictatorship in the face of
any sign of dissidence they were created
just over 40 years ago and dress in
black to be intimidating there's
something akin to the praetorian guard
of the communist regime
we train to defend the revolution and to
defend our conquests at alberto soriano
vidal major of the special national
brigade but let's not get sidetracked by
cool outfits okay maybe the end of this
attribute in cuba has not yet come but
how much longer will the cuban
dictatorship last
for the time being it already had to
give on something that seemed
insurmountable until just a month ago
restrictions on private imports cuba
lifts food medicine customs restrictions
after protest which by the way is
curious the u.s embargo that punishes
the island is often mentioned but it is
never the embargo established by the
cuban government itself that is the
restrictions on trading with the outside
world in any case if one thing is clear
is that the unprecedented social
explosion that took place in july 2021
has been a desperate cry that although
it has not succeeded in overthrowing the
dictatorship it served to make the
desire for democracy in cuba heard
around the world and it is precisely at
this point that we come to the future
political agenda
[Music]
let's be clear if the communist party of
cuba wants to continue ruling the island
it will have no choice but to carry out
real economic reforms market-orientated
reforms as deng xiaoping did in china on
the other hand if they continue to
refuse to change the model the tide may
soon sweep them away or the
international community may even say
enough is enough to what has been an
unsustainable situation for decades a
repressive and outdated communist
dictatorship a few miles from miami but
at this point it's over to you will diaz
canel and his cronies be willing to
modernize cuba in order to keep their
seats will the protests result in a cuba
with more social and economic freedoms
or will the government opt for the path
of more and more repression and what
positions should the international
community adopt you can leave us your
opinion here below in the comments and
by the way if you like this video don't
forget to give us a like and subscribe
to the channel by clicking on the little
bell down there so you don't miss any
updates once again thank you for
watching and i'll see you all next time
you